time for us to get to our draft for
today the biggest legacy boost from a
super bowl win who would get it that's
our draft chris you get the first pick
if you get the trivia question right the
buccaneers haven't won a home playoff
game since the 2002 divisional round
who did they beat in that game i mean
really the year before i got there you
don't you guys don't think i'm gonna
know that you know how many cut-ups i
watch from that game to learn the
offense the san francisco 49ers and jeff
garcia came to town the buccaneers
handled them then they went on to
philadelphia my man rondae barber got
that pick six at the end to close that
out to go to the super bowl you can't
mess with me in that stuff come on pete
what are you doing thanks pete thanks
pete all right um you got the first pick
this is actually kind of tough it really
is because there's some legit you know
legacies i i think the guy we just
talked about i gotta go with him number
one i think it's the it's the most
important for bruce arians like bruce
aryan's legacy you know again he's never
been to the super bowl so that just
bolstered his legacy now hey i'm here
you win the super bowl against the
chiefs and patrick mahomes and andy reid
and do it with you know tom brady at
quarterback and all those things i got
to think that he gets the biggest boost
from a super bowl win this weekend
see i'm surprised and maybe you were
just influenced by the fact that we just
were talking about it but it's got to be
tom brady what have you been saying ever
since he got to six he wants to get to
set sure why because seven is one more
than michael jordan and you've predicted
if he gets to seven he walks away i
frank doesn't seem like that's happening
no way no he's not one i think he's
gonna play until he's 50 at this point
the way he's going and uh so he's going
to stretch that rubber band as far as he
can but number seven for him
that to me would be the biggest boost
because now you're already starting to
hear people raise the question of
whether he's the greatest athlete of all
time which i am not ready to sign on for
but you get to seven championships and
you get to a super bowl with a second
team at age 43
you start taking a look at it and you
say he's the best something i don't know
that it's athlete is it best competitor
is it i don't know yeah but he's the
best he's the best at something if he
gets to number seven yeah he's amazing i
mean there's no doubt about it best
athlete ever absolutely not that is like
ludicrous i mean ludicrous insane just
the fact that people are starting to say
i know
the stratosphere he's approaching i i
get it but it's you know again the
stratosphere we're talking about with
this guy is so much team related i just
can't take it anymore to the point where
i'm gonna i feel like i have to root for
the chiefs because i'm just sick of the
nonsense talk all the time i mean you
have to root for the cheese because your
son won't let you root well i'm just
like it's just everything if the defense
makes a play now and i turn the tv on
and people are like it was brady he
wheeled them from the bench that's why
the guy made the sack he was willed
brady was thinking sack the guy and then
the guy sacked him and i just i'm so
sick of hearing it i just can't take it
i've i've watched all of the playoff
games i don't recall anyone actually
saying that no i'm talking about
just talking heads during the week on
the show it's a he gets
he willed the defense to make the stop
inside the 10-yard line like get the
hell out of here with that crap get the
hell out of here he's awesome he's the
most accomplished ever he's not even the
most talented quarterback ever let alone
the greatest athlete ever that's insane
okay move on and i disagree with your
pick his legacy is already the best
legacy in the history of football he
can't improve it's a horrible pick by
you here we go better with seven i'm
going to patrick mahomes as my next one
though i am because when you become a
quarterback that wins two super bowls it
does knock you into a next another
stratosphere and i think with a legacy
to add to where okay it's you know two
super goals in a row the the season
before that was an afc championship game
where his team
they had brady and the patriots on the
ropes and of course if d4 just doesn't
line up offsides they're going to win
the game but then i think what adds to
this is you beat brady in the super bowl
and in his home field and all those type
of things too i just think increases the
mahomes legacy to go now oh wait maybe
he can chase down a brady to be the most
accomplished ever and do those type of
things
this is a two-game swing yeah it's
either gonna be seven and one or six and
two he's gonna be six back or four back
based upon this game i gotta go with
andy reid yeah for my next one right
yeah last year was the arrival of a guy
who's been in coaching for 20 years and
he finally got his due you get to number
two it's a different five and you got
number three coming potentially and
maybe number four and maybe number five
and then all of a sudden maybe you're up
there with bill belichick so i i think
that it's not just because of what it
means to have two it's the next step
toward three four and five that's why
it's so big for andy reid yeah i i'm i'm
with you that i was torn between him and
my homes but again like the list is
short right for two-time super bowl
head coaching champions i mean that
that's a pretty primed list right there
and then of course you know the third
appearance all together all that i'm
with you i can get behind that this
one's where i'm i'm i'm a little
you know in between here i don't know
where to go
right it is harder now doesn't it well
because i think of like tyree kill he
had a hundred yards last year receiving
you know with the way they play you
think he could do that in this game and
you know now add to his overall super
bowl stats and lure and everything like
that
i think i'm gonna go with steve spagnola
though i think i am gonna do that
i think there's something to be gained
here i know he's made a comment here in
the last day or two about he'd like a
chance to be a head coach once again you
know that didn't go great for him the
first time around
but what what whoa
it was a disaster disaster the first
time around it was exactly a complete
and total disaster the point where they
could shut the bucks out on sunday and i
don't think that phone's ringing well no
it's not ringing this year certainly not
but i do think it does something to his
legacy as far as i don't great defensive
minds of all time clutch coordinators of
all time you know this could be the
second time he could go i beat tom brady
in the super bowl and he was their
offenses were damn good both times i we
beat him so between that and then of
course you know what they did to
shanahan and that offense last year i
think that could be pretty big boost for
him
i'm looking for a guy on both rosters
and i'm scanning them with part of my
brain while i say this
a guy
whose hall of fame case benefits the
most right from a super bowl win because
we know that a super bowl win is going
to matter and when you consider
all the baggage because it's easy to
forget what he did from 2011 oh
whoa
are you i know where you're about to go
here we go
you you give antonio brown a super bowl
ring
and uh and and also
assuming he continues with the
buccaneers and they want him and he
should want them he stayed out of
trouble ever since he's gotten there
having that super bowl ring gives him a
different vibe when it's time to start
picking out the hall of fame receivers
of the past 20 years so i think it helps
him more than it helps any of the other
players from the standpoint of what that
ring means to the possibility of getting
a bronze bust that'd be interesting to
know if it does give him a boost that
way i mean you're right i mean really
he's a hall of fame player we know that
but is it you know is it been skewed by
all the off the field stuff or ever
shouldn't be i know i know not supposed
to no right o.j simpson's still in there
of course his stuff came later but
plenty of guys are in there definitely
who had
off-field issues that were well-known
and they still got in i think it will do
more
justice to the ring especially if he
comes back next year and then is a
contributor to the football team then it
kind of shows like hey he was part of
the fabric of that super bowl team and
all that but if it's just like hey he
was on that team and he didn't even play
in the playoffs and doesn't play in the
super bowl i don't know if you get quite
the credit that that's what's kind of uh
be interesting about it
he's got to play in the game yeah i
agree with you yeah but look at what's
going to happen next year chris godwin's
going to leave as a free agent you're
not going to be able to keep him they're
not going to be able to justify it so
it's going to be evans and brown as the
starters next year
with scotty miller with tyler johnson
yeah they're still going to be great
and they're going they're going to be
great and brown's going to get wire to
wire all season long assuming that that
the buccaneers keep him and he wants to
stay but i think that's exactly what is
going to happen all right uh that was a
fun draft the first two rounds were very
easy and then all of a sudden it was
like oh crap what are we gonna do
in round three but i i like our picks
from both
sides
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports